why don't we go next to um
let's go to matt from washington dc
you're on the air
hey how you doing david doing well thank
you well my
question was um you know during the
initial debates before the 2020 election
um biden got asked a couple questions
about whether or not he was going to
pack the court and
you know that whole slew of things yeah
and you know he's kind of said that he
wants to do some
you know judicial review or you know get
like a group of
both conserve you know republicans and
democrats to
come up with a way to you know change
something
in the future if you could you know wave
a magic wand and
decide how would you you know
restructure the
supreme court mostly you know how would
you end up doing it i have a few ideas
of my own
but i'd like to hear your opinion on the
matter i'm open to a number of different
things but i like the idea of term
limits for supreme court justices for
sure
i'm open to the idea of a rotation where
you actually are rotated from
um on to and back
off of the supreme court i think is an
interesting one that i've heard
suggested in the past
the idea of just adding adding adding
more and more people i think you don't
really need to do that
if you can get on a sort of regular
rotation where
uh it's sort of it doesn't depend on
retiring or dying
you you know exactly when the
the president will get an opportunity to
to select someone new
i think that's really the biggest reform
that's needed
yeah i definitely agree i would put the
number somewhere around 18
20 years that allows for you know a
judge can still affect you know a
quote-unquote generation
but nowadays they're just living so long
they're getting you know
two you know 20 years to get into 25
years and
that's easily yeah it could be 18 20 but
i've i've even read that 12 to 14 would
be logical in some sense it just has to
be aligned with presidential terms in a
way that makes sense
you know that is i didn't think about
that um also as well
um you know people have also talked
about packing the court is i know nine
does it i mean does nine have a very
specific reason why there is nine or
you know would you make it you know 11
15 as long as it's an odd number of
course
yeah i have no particular reason why i
think it should be a larger
odd number it's nine because that's the
number it was most recently expanded to
um again i think if you fix the other
things i don't think we need more than
nine
okay so i mean so in the future when we
do you know do this kind of reform how
do we
you know with how partisan politics is
tended to be
how do you go into that initial
transition you you have to basically set
up a schedule you have to
the if you can get elected officials to
agree to it would you
what you would say is okay um we need we
need a transition period and the
transition period is going to be
that in the order in which they were
put on the court uh starting with the
person who's been
on the court the longest let's say we
decide these are 14-year terms
how many people currently are beyond 14
years
uh if there's a bunch then you just have
to come up with an interim schedule if
there's
none then you say all right well then as
they get to 14
we're going to start replacing them in
some cases you may
say someone gets to stay longer just so
you can get like
there there's got to be some way where
there would be
every x number of years one of the
justices
is replaced and then you just know in
advance what years that's going to
happen and there's no wondering about
which president will get to do it
okay i mean that's definitely you
definitely put more thought into it than
i have but that isn't
i like that idea better than you know
what i had i was generally
thinking of keeping it roughly similar
but having
you know term limits and then you know
maybe adding
more judges in the future or you know
something like that but
a rotating schedule is definitely sounds
like an objectively better
uh set up than what we currently have
all right very good appreciate the call
thanks so much for calling in
uh that is going to do it for today as
always i apologize i wasn't able to
speak to
everybody and there are lots of people
waiting but we will take calls again
and i appreciate everybody who called in
one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman